in india coronavirus cases have
surpassed 5 million and
more than 82 000 people have died health
experts warn that
the fatality rate could rise as
restrictions ease
authorities have so far ruled out
imposing a second country-wide lockdown
india home to 1.3 billion people has
reported some of the
highest daily case jumps in the world
it's expected to overtake the united
states as
the country worst hit by the pandemic
within
the coming weeks
joining me now is dws india
correspondent nimisha jazwa from
delhi indonesia india's coronavirus
cases as we've just heard have
surpassed 5 million that's the second
highest in the world after the us yet
the deaths are still comparatively
low why is that well gerhard there's
just scientific investigations going on
to confirm what exactly is the cause of
this
but experts have put forward theories
one is that india's population is a
young
one much younger than when compared to
developed nations which were much
worse hit such as italy in addition
there's also a theory of cross
reactivity
this basically means that india's
population and other developing
countries populations
have been exposed to other coronaviruses
which has actually allowed these
populations to fight off this
coronavirus
in a better way of course critics say
that the fatalities may be undercounted
so we
should not focus that much on the
fertility rates and the relative success
india has had in keeping depths down
well we're hearing that oxygen
supplies are running low in india can
you tell us more about that
yes so oxygen basically across india is
supplied by approximately 500 factories
that distill and purify oxygen and
supply it
in the past about less than a fifth of
this was being used for health care
and the rest was being directed to
factories to uh to
power blast furnaces for example however
now with the case load
rising dramatically the demand for
oxygen from the health sector
has gone up dramatically as well now
over half the oxygen in india
produces is being directed to health
care but there are unlocked phases in
place in india so the factories are
firing up again
and also demanding oxygen it's almost a
case of lives versus livelihoods and
india
urgently requires to ramp up its oxygen
supply dramatically
well india's government has rejected a
second country-wide lockdown and is
continuing to lift restrictions what's
the public feeling there
about this strategy
well despite the frightening numbers and
the grim milestones we keep arriving at
in
india gerhard the people actually agree
with the government
that another lockdown is unlikely to
help the government has said that while
people must continue to take precautions
we must learn to live with the
coronavirus and the people seem to agree
india saw one of its worst gdp quarterly
contractions
in the last few months and there are
serious concerns about the
massive impact the two-month complete
lockdown we saw in india
has on the economy already and people as
well as the government say that we must
part through
live with the pandemic and try our best
to jump up infrastructure
as well as support in developing a
vaccine
dws nimisha chesmar in delhi thank you
very much
you